for Asian American and Pacific Islander
heritage month we're introducing you to
aapi leaders Fiona kochan started her
Makeup Company euthoria in Euphoria
don't want to mess up the name of the
company in 2021. she wanted to invent
makeup good enough for your skin that
you can sleep in it that's what I say
too Nate say what now her products are
sold in Alton JCPenney thank you very
much in stores across the country the
brand gained popularity on Tick Tock for
its blush oil that changes colors to
match your skin tone Fiona cochan we're
very proud to say joins us in studio
very good to see you Fiona really great
to be here today okay so my makeup
artist radon Books use your makeup on me
today I'm going to get right in your
face is it okay up close and personal
yeah up close and personal but this is
the thing that struck me about your
makeup when they said you could sleep in
it because we're always told wash your
face every night do not sleep in your
makeup you clearly feel differently
about that why
I always grew up and I was always told
you should never sleep in your makeup
yeah I am someone who let's say I'm out
late or let's say I'm working late I
always accidentally fall asleep in my
makeup previously I used to work in Tech
and I would actually travel to Asia a
lot and I was always getting on these
long 14-hour flights and I was always
falling asleep in my makeup and I would
wake up with just these really bad
reactions these really bad breakouts
sometimes this would send me to the
hospital and I was like you know what I
just really want makeup if I
accidentally ever fell asleep in it my
skin would be okay how hard was it to
make to come up with a formula that
would work in that way originally it was
really difficult because I think you
know you always thought that makeup was
on one side and skincare was on the
other side but what we do differently is
we combine really nice texturing
ingredients on the makeup and then
skincare ingredients that are functional
so that you can get the best of both
worlds so there's a bunch of ways to
test makeup but there was a unique way
that you tested it with your husband
right yeah so we're best known for our
BYO blush it's the world's first color
changing blush oil so it reacts to your
Skin's pH to give you the perfect shade
so this is something that looks
different on everyone but I had it's
amazing the idea to Great sport yeah to
create the product during the pandemic
and my husband was really the only
person that was kind of interacting with
so I swatched it on him and it was a
different color on him than it was on me
and I had the idea to test it by
sleeping in it and that next morning I
woke up with such bright and beautiful
skin I had to ask him to sleep it in as
well so now we test all of our products
by sleeping in it for two months and you
all are still married still married no
you're a little surprised in that video
like he wasn't sure I know I think what
it is is he here you know a couple that
make up together I didn't wake up
together again hello hello husband but
you say it's good you say it's good for
all ages and all skin tones yeah
something I really wanted to do was be
inclusive at the formulation level so I
think about all skin tones skin types
textures and ages I'm always thinking
about will this work for let's say the
13 year old girl who might be struggling
with hormonal acne as well as my mother
who's post-menopausal has a completely
different set of skin concerns I can
relate to Mom and so why do you call it
Euphoria so Euphoria refers to that
feeling that you get when you're really
happy in your adult life and you're
reminded of your favorite childhood
memories so for me it's like the first
time my mom allowed me to buy lip gloss
or it's like those really happy meals I
had with my grandparents so uh when
people reach your stage of the game
you've got a product out there people
love it you're on air with us I always
like to ask for advice for people who
are who are starting out where where you
were once upon a time what advice do you
have for younger entrepreneurs I think
it's just to start you learn so much
about yourself just by starting you
develop such a sense of resiliency and I
always like to tell tell people if
you're doing something that no one has
ever done before you don't need to have
imposter syndrome and you got to be bold
and quit your job in Tech because that's
what you did how did your family take
that they were so supportive my mom the
first thing she said was just do what
your heart desires that's awesome he was
just so supportive in this whole journey
I love if you haven't done it before you
don't have to have imposter syndrome
that's right yeah I appreciate it yeah I
am yeah Tony you want to try it and test
it out sure if I get a little color on
the cheeks in the morning that's nice
well we appreciate you joining us thank
you so much Euphoria is available make
sure you try some